Katrina: 把碟子吃吧
Katrina: Just eat off the plate.
Alice:这名字
Alice: This name...
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Katrina: 就是
Katrina: Exactly.
Alice:咋办吃
Alice: How do we eat?
Katrina: 不是没有碗了吗
Katrina: Aren't there no bowls?
Alice:我说我说
Alice: I mean, I mean...
Alice:这名字也挺好玩的哎
Alice: This name is pretty funny, huh.
Alice:这不好多筷子吗
Alice: Aren't there a lot of chopsticks?
Alice:我操给你个筷子
Alice: Damn, here's a pair of chopsticks for you.
Alice:你有筷子吗
Alice: Do you have chopsticks?
Lucia: 这饮料有人喝吗
Lucia: Is anyone drinking this beverage?
Katrina: 昨天是到了你可以直接对
Katrina: Yesterday it arrived, you can just...
Alice:昨天是谁的
Alice: Whose was it yesterday?
Lucia: 那我对嘴喝
Lucia: Then I'll drink it directly.
Lucia: 还有人要喝吗
Lucia: Does anyone else want to drink it?
Jake:如果海那我拿个杯子呢
Jake: If there's more, I'll get a cup.
Alice:米饭给咱俩分一个
Alice: Let's share this rice.
Jake:我哎整一点你们要吗
Jake: I'll just take a bit, do you guys want some?
Jake:我多拿几个杯子来吧
Jake: I'll get a few more cups.
Katrina: 杯子都没洗
Katrina: The cups aren't washed.
Jake:我拿12345678
Jake: I'll take 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
Alice:咱俩分分
Alice: Let's share it.
Alice:我是我用这个吃你用这个吃啊
Alice: I'll eat with this, and you eat with that.
Jake:那行吧
Jake: Alright then.
Katrina: 这有碟子药吗
Katrina: Are there any plates?
Alice:好吗咱俩可以啊
Alice: It's fine, we can share.
Katrina: 有碟子要吗
Katrina: Do you need a plate?
Alice:呦，用谢谢
Alice: Oh, thanks.
Alice:给你用盘
Alice: Here, use a plate.
其他人：真好哈哈哈
Others: So nice, haha.
Alice:啊靠上面好油
Alice: Ah, the top is so greasy.
其他人：我自己来行了吧
Others: I'll do it myself, okay?
Lucia: 嗯很像好像跟我记忆中
Lucia: Hmm, it looks like how I remember it.
Alice:木须肉吧
Alice: Mu Shu pork, right?
Jake:对这是木须肉
Jake: Yep, it's Mu Shu pork.
Jake:哈哈哈这杯子是不用了吧
Jake: Haha, we don't need this cup, right?
Jake:这杯子是没用了吧
Jake: This cup is useless, right?
Alice:不用了哈哈
Alice: Yeah, we don't need it, haha.
Jake:好的那就用这个吧
Jake: Alright, then we'll use this one.
Lucia: 我觉得8个人吃哇哈哈哈
Lucia: I think 8 people can eat, haha
Jake:对
Jake: Yeah
Lucia: 用来喝水的吗OK
Lucia: Is this for drinking water? OK
Lucia: 8个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋还
Lucia: 8 people eating two plates of scrambled eggs
Alice:哦我不用了
Alice: Oh, I don't need it
其他人：这怎么不算纸杯呢
Others: How does this not count as a paper cup?
Lucia: 两个人吃两盘炒鸡蛋多少
Lucia: Two people eating two plates of scrambled eggs, how much?
Shure: 这是什么啊纸纸杯啊
Shure: What is this, a paper cup?
Alice:这什么呀
Alice: What is this?
Jake:纸杯呀
Jake: It's a paper cup
Alice:喝饮料的
Shure: 不是
Shure: No
Lucia: 哈哈
Shure: 杨老板太幽默了吧
Shure: Jake, you're so funny
Jake:这怎么了
Jake: What's wrong?
Jake:不能喝吗
Jake: Can't you drink?
Alice:太幽默了
Jake:不能喝
Jake: Can't drink
Lucia: 我想知道AI会怎么解释这个行为啊
Lucia: I wonder how AI would explain this behavior
Jake:就是这是一个杯子吗
Jake: It's just a cup, right?
Katrina: 没用完的继续用
Katrina: Keep using the unfinished one
Jake:对
Jake: Right
Shure: 那我们后期打标注怎么打
Shure: So how do we label it in post-production?
Shure: 到底是这个是cup还是那个纸杯是cup
Shure: Is this a cup or is the paper cup a cup?
Jake:这不都是Cup吗
Jake: Aren't they both cups?
Shure: 这这咖啡真的能装水吗
Shure: Can this coffee really hold water?
Jake:为啥不能实验一下
Jake: Why not give it a try?
Lucia: 实验一下
Lucia: Give it a try
Lucia: 我们要有科学精神
Lucia: We need to have a scientific spirit
Shure: 来杨老板你拿这提一杯哈哈哈
Shure: Come on, Jake, you take a cup, haha
Jake:哎那我先带头
Jake: Alright, I'll go first
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Lucia: 看起来好容易洒啊
Lucia: Looks easy to spill
Jake:给给给您给您斟上
Jake: Here, let me pour you some
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha
Jake:给您斟上
Jake: Let me pour you some
Lucia: 那我自己来
Lucia: I'll do it myself
Lucia: 哈哈哈谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Hahaha, thank you, thank you.
Lucia: 辛苦你了
Lucia: You worked hard.
Alice:给你一块
Alice: Here, have a piece.
Lucia: 倒这么小一个杯子不洒
Lucia: Pouring into such a small cup without spilling.
Alice:你吃着这个吧
Alice: You eat this.
Alice:我咋吃不吃
Alice: Why don't I eat?
Jake:哈哈你们还修硕也喝吗
Jake: Hahaha, are you and Shure also drinking?
Shure: 啊来
Shure: Ah, come on.
Jake:那来点吧
Jake: Then have some.
Jake:整点
Jake: Get some.
Shure: 我先不来我先不来
Shure: I'll pass for now, I'll pass for now.
Jake:哈哈哈都不来了
Jake: Hahaha, no one wants to drink.
Jake:要吗
Jake: Do you want some?
Jake:别的都不要好嘞
Jake: No, it's alright.
Jake:干杯
Jake: Cheers!
Jake:干完了好干杯
Jake: Finished it, good, cheers!
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Oh no.
Jake:他喝啥了喝多了
Jake: What did he drink, drank too much?
Lucia: 干杯cheers
Lucia: Cheers, cheers!
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: G
Shure: G.
Lucia: 毫不意外
Lucia: Not surprising at all.
Lucia:  这要不能放这个
Lucia: This can't be placed here.
Jake:可以
Jake: It can.
Jake:可以这太妙了
Jake: It can, this is great.
Jake:这些设施妙啊
Jake: These facilities are wonderful.
Lucia: 妙啊
Lucia: Wonderful.
Jake:确实很妙
Jake: Really wonderful.
Lucia: 因为这个盘稍微有点小有点软
Lucia: Because this plate is a bit small and soft.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah.
Shure: 有点湿是吗
Shure: A bit wet, right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Shure: 土豆怎么了
Shure: What's with the potatoes?
Jake:给筷子
Jake: Get the chopsticks.
其他人：我感觉有点生啊
Others: I feel it's a bit raw.
Lucia: 这我怎么没看出是什么
Lucia: I can't tell what this is.
Shure: 拿下北欧南了吗
Shure: Did you take over Northern Europe?
Shure: 不知道了是吗
Shure: You don't know, right?
Lucia: 辣死
Lucia: It's so spicy.
Katrina: 你就别提了行吗
Katrina: Can you stop talking about it?
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha
Katrina: 我再也不喝酒
Katrina: I will never drink again.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Shure: 放心只会有0次和无数次
Shure: Don't worry, it's either zero times or countless times.
Jake:哦你这凳子大了点
Jake: Oh, your chair is a bit big.
Lucia: 哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Lucia: 我说之前搬凳子算了
Lucia: I said we should just move the chairs earlier.
Jake:好吧
Jake: Alright.
其他人：你觉得附近有没有什么好吃的
Others: Do you think there’s any good food around here?
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Jake:还能坚持一天
Jake: We can hang on for a day.
Jake:挺强的
Jake: Pretty strong.
Alice:你非得在附近找干嘛
Alice: Why do you insist on finding something nearby?
Shure: 确实因为因为会很难受
Shure: Because it would be really uncomfortable.
Alice:我们就不能去远点
Alice: Can't we go a bit further?
Alice:也是
Alice: Yeah, true.
Shure: 是真的闻到那个味我就想吐
Shure: If I smell that, I want to puke.
Alice:我咋了
Alice: What’s wrong with me?
Tasha: 分散一点
Tasha: Spread out a bit.
Alice:做什么春秋大梦
Alice: What kind of daydreaming are you doing?
其他人：OK只能中午吃是吧
Others: Okay, so we can only eat at noon, right?
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:木须肉是没有肉吗
Jake: Does Moo Shu Pork not have pork?
Jake:是有肉肉丝是吗
Jake: It’s got pork shreds, right?
Alice:那不是肉吗
Alice: Isn’t that pork?
Lucia: 是不是很有迷惑性
Lucia: Isn't it confusing?
Jake:哼哼肉丝很少
Jake: Hmm, there’s very little pork.
Alice:你会做饭吗
Alice: Can you cook?
Alice:符合
Alice: Makes sense.
Jake:我来问问木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Jake: Let me ask why it’s called Moo Shu Pork.
Lucia: 好问题我也想知道嗯
Lucia: Good question, I want to know too.
Alice:木是木耳吗
Alice: Is the "Moo" referring to wood ear mushrooms?
Shure: 不是
Shure: No.
Jake:那是啥呀
Jake: Then what is it?
Shure: 他是苜蓿是苜蓿
Shure: It's alfalfa, it's alfalfa.
Jake:木须肉为
Jake: Moo Shu Pork...
Jake:啥是木须肉啊
Jake: What is Moo Shu Pork?
Shure: 木须肉为什么叫木须肉
Shure: Why is Moo Shu Pork called Moo Shu Pork?
Jake:看你俩GPT时间长吧哼
Jake: You two have been GPT-ing for too long, huh.
Shure: 肯定我的嫌快
Shure: Definitely, mine is faster.
Jake:我是上海GPT
Jake: I am Shanghai GPT.
Jake:你这是哪
Jake: Where are you from?
Shure: 我这个
Shure: I'm from...
Jake:哈哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahahaha
Tasha: 你输了哈哈哈哈
Tasha: You lost, hahaha.
Katrina: 嗯是有点
Katrina: Hmm, it's a bit...
Katrina: 那边福建广东话
Katrina: That side speaks Fujian and Cantonese.
Katrina: 那是上海话他的
Katrina: That's Shanghainese.
Alice:哎
Alice: Oh.
Shure: 这好磁性啊
Shure: This is so magnetic.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Shure: 我好喜欢你的声音
Shure: I really like your voice.
Katrina: 完了
Katrina: It's over.
Shure: 你可以对我说一些情话吗
Shure: Can you say some sweet words to me?
Jake:刚问完木须肉
Jake: Just asked about Moo Shu Pork.
Katrina: 这样也能撩
Katrina: You can flirt like this too?
Katrina: 竹子学习中哈哈哈
Katrina: Bamboo is studying, hahaha.
Katrina: 独自学习
Katrina: Studying alone.
Jake:就是情话是吧暧昧期
Jake: So it's sweet talk, right? During the ambiguous period.
Shure: 好的宝贝
Shure: Okay, baby.
Katrina: 暧昧期说的话
Katrina: Words during the ambiguous period.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 他他妈是你教的吧
Shure: Did you teach him that?
Shure: 怎么说半道开始说英文了呢
Shure: Why did he start speaking English halfway through?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:没
Alice: No.
Shure: 对不起
Shure: Sorry.
Jake:你让GPT少喝点哈哈哈
Jake: Tell GPT to drink less, hahaha.
Shure: 别提了算了
Shure: Don't mention it, forget it.
Shure: 不揭你老底了
Shure: I won't reveal your secrets.
Lucia: sorry sorry
Lucia: Sorry, sorry.
Alice:哇刚看见
Alice: Wow, just noticed.
Alice:不负众望啊真是
Alice: You really lived up to expectations.
Jake:哦哦
Jake: Oh, oh.
Alice:我以为我今天不用洗衣服了呢
Alice: I thought I wouldn't have to do laundry today.
Jake:他俩也要洗了
Jake: They have to do laundry too.
Alice:居然了
Alice: Really?
Jake:救命他俩也要洗了
Jake: Help! They have to do laundry too.
Alice:算了不是明显待会洗
Alice: Forget it, it's obvious we'll wash it later.
Jake:我这其实也要洗
Jake: I actually need to wash mine too.
Jake:但是我已经弃疗了
Jake: But I've already given up.
Alice:就这样吧
Alice: Let's just leave it like this.
Lucia: 挺好一桌八分人又四个都要洗衣服
Lucia: It's funny, out of eight people at the table, four need to wash their clothes.
Lucia: 就是虽然你不洗
Lucia: Even though you don't wash yours...
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I wash mine every day.
Lucia: 但是你理论上是要洗嗯是
Lucia: But theoretically, you should be washing it, right?
Jake:嗯是
Jake: Yeah, right.
Alice:我每天都在洗
Alice: I wash mine every day.
Alice:因为我每次吃饭都会弄衣服上
Alice: Because I always spill food on my clothes when I eat.
Alice:然后还带的都是潜意识
Alice: It's like a subconscious habit.
Lucia: 对而且吃饭弄衣服上得赶快洗
Lucia: Yeah, and if you spill food on your clothes, you have to wash it quickly.
Lucia: 如果不赶快洗洗不掉了
Lucia: If you don't wash it quickly, the stain won't come out.
Lucia: 现在洗就洗掉了现在洗就洗掉了
Lucia: If you wash it now, the stain will come out. If you wash it now, it will come out.
Tasha: 现在洗就洗掉了
Tasha: If you wash it now, it will come out.
Tasha: 嗯
Tasha: Yeah.
Jake:有点厉害
Jake: That's impressive.
Alice:算了我也给他洗了吧
Alice: Forget it, I'll wash his too.
Alice:真服了你
Alice: I'm really impressed with you.
其他人：真贪心呢
Others: So greedy.
其他人：连吃带拿的
Others: Eating and taking everything.
Alice:你吃吧给
Alice: Here, you eat.
Alice:哎呦
Alice: Ouch.
Tasha: 嗯我跟他聊了一会
Tasha: Yeah, I chatted with him for a bit.
Alice:没人看到
Alice: No one saw that.
Tasha: 是不是我第一天发烧说传给他了
Tasha: Did I pass it to him when I had a fever on my first day?
Tasha: 然后我好了他发烧
Tasha: Then I got better, and he got a fever.
Alice:喂我会不会吃着吃着又掉了
Alice: Hey, will I spill my food again while eating?
其他人：那说不准
Others: That’s hard to say.
Alice:我应该买个吃饭用的围裙
Alice: I should buy an apron for eating.
Alice:肚兜围兜
Alice: Like a bib apron.
其他人：你拿个围嘴得了
Others: Just get a bib.
Alice:什么围嘴啊
Alice: What bib?
Alice:就那个小孩用的
Alice: Like the one kids use.
Shure: 我在吃中午饭
Shure: I'm having lunch.
Shure: 你可以给我讲一个
Shure: Can you tell me a joke about lunch?
Shure: 关于中午饭的笑话吗
Katrina: 玩一天是吧
Katrina: Playing all day, right?
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Shure: 完了他卡住了
Shure: Oh no, it's stuck.
Jake:有有道理
Jake: Yeah, that makes sense.
Lucia: 哇这个凳子太难移动
Lucia: Wow, this chair is hard to move.
Jake:哎呀哈哈哈哈
Jake: Oh gosh, hahaha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Shure: 哈
Shure: Ha.
Alice:哈
Alice: Ha.
Jake:吃点那个
Jake: Have some of that.
Jake:流水席走一波
Jake: Let's have a feast.
Shure: 再见再见
Shure: Goodbye, goodbye.
Tasha: 这个是你干的吗
Tasha: Did you do this?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Tasha: 干完了吗
Tasha: Is it done?
Jake:不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:总查查干的
Jake: Jack did it.
Jake:这不是我干的
Jake: It wasn't me.
Jake:哦这个
Jake: Oh, this.
Jake:这个他屋子里边的这小彩旗串一半
Jake: The small flags in his room are halfway done.
Jake:这是什么
Jake: What is this?
Jake:这也是
Jake: This too.
Jake:我靠
Jake: Damn.
Jake:悬崖勒马
Jake: Stop right there.
Jake:耶
Jake: Yay.
Alice:我的天呐
Alice: Oh my god.
Jake:哎呦
Jake: Ouch.
Shure: 我记得
Shure: I remember.
Shure: 他这个会用一个非常磁性的声音
Shure: He would use a very magnetic voice.
Shure: 跟你念什么
Shure: To say something to you.
Jake:他拒绝了也是吧
Jake: He refused, didn't he?
Shure: 我想听一点成人的内容
Shure: I want to hear some adult content. 社会问题
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
其他人：你学校门口有这个
Others: Do you have this at your school gate?
Alice:可以走
Alice: You can go.
Jake:真简单
Jake: So simple.
Jake:哎呀
Jake: Oh dear.
Shure: 完了是我服务不到位了
Shure: Oh no, I didn't serve well.
Shure: 老板来给
Shure: Boss, here you go
Jake:那没晚了晚了
Jake: Oh, it's too late, too late
Alice:晚了
Alice: Too late
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 老板爱吃这个
Shure: Boss loves eating this
Shure: 早说呀哎呀
Shure: Should've said earlier, oh man
Jake:哈
Jake: Haha
Shure: 放放放他面前
Shure: Put it in front of him
Alice:哎呀油油油
Alice: Oh no, oil, oil
Lucia: 行
Lucia: Okay
Lucia: 这次离老离老板最近也是两盘炒鸡蛋
Lucia: This time, the two closest dishes to the boss are scrambled eggs
Jake:好
Jake: Good
Lucia: 当我的领导就必须得吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Being my boss means you have to eat scrambled eggs
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Lucia: 以后在我简单里加一点
Lucia: Next time, add some more
Lucia:  擅长迫使领导吃炒鸡蛋
Lucia: Skilled at making the boss eat scrambled eggs
Jake:可以
Jake: Sure
Tasha: 这个好像不是很强迫的样子
Tasha: This doesn't seem very forced
Alice:你喝点不喝
Alice:饮料
Alice: Want a drink?
其他人：什么
其他人：不喝喝白开水
Jake:谢谢
Jake: Thanks
Lucia: 不用谢
Lucia: No problem
Alice:白开水
Alice: Plain water
Lucia: 这个杯子倒的时候真的有一种喜感
Lucia: Pouring from this cup really has a funny feeling
Tasha: 天才
Tasha: Genius
Katrina: 像古代的那种
Katrina: Like something from ancient times
Jake:嗯对小酒盏哦
Jake: Yeah, like a small wine cup
其他人：你的菠萝蛋糕已经到了
Others: Your pineapple cake has arrived
Tasha: 哦
Tasha: Oh
Alice:好
Alice: Good
Alice:明天续上
Alice: Continue tomorrow
Tasha: 就剩这么点了你就不能给老板倒掉啊
Tasha: There's just a little left, can't you pour it for the boss?
Alice:我都没看过呀
Alice: I didn't even see it
Alice:你数一下位数不得了吗
Alice: Can't you just count the digits?
Alice:11位啊
Alice: 11 digits, right?
Jake:干了
Jake: Done
Alice:这不正常的吗
Alice: Isn't that normal?
Alice:干嘛你被人夺射了
Alice: Why, were you shot by someone?
Alice:身上有脏东西
Alice: There's something dirty on you
其他人：不是我寻思用这个
Others: I thought we were using this.
其他人：他不是一般都是取件码吗
Others: Isn't it usually a pickup code?
其他人：取件码不都8位吗
Others: Aren't pickup codes usually 8 digits?
Alice:也有6位啊
Alice: There are also 6-digit ones.
其他人：那你这是
Others: Then what is this?
Alice:这我一般都不用
Alice: I usually don't use this.
Alice:我直接就是那个复制那个订单号
Alice: I just copy the order number.
Alice:然后找一下他那个取件码就行了
Alice: And then I look up the pickup code.
Jake:咱还有快递吗
Jake: Do we have any more packages?
Jake:今也可以有
Jake: We can have some today.
Alice:没有这是我
Alice: No, this is mine.
Jake:啊哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 谁藏了这种好东西
Shure: Who hid such a good thing?
Shure: 居然不交公
Shure: And didn't share it.
Shure: 是不是你藏的
Shure: Was it you who hid it?
Lucia: 这是维生素片吗
Lucia: Are these vitamin pills?
Alice:健胃消食片
Lucia: 这能吃饱吗
Lucia: Can you feel full with these?
Jake:哈哈哈这几片看来不行
Jake: Hahaha, a few of these won't be enough.
Alice:可以哈哈
Alice: Yes, haha.
其他人：拿他当糖吃
Others: Treat them like candy.
Lucia: 但我小时候真的好奇过这个问题哦
Lucia: But I was really curious about this as a kid.
Jake:Lucia:
Jake: Lucia:
Lucia: 就是它本身是占一定的体积的
Lucia: It does take up some space in your stomach.
Lucia: 所以吃下去它更饱
Lucia: So it makes you feel full.
Lucia: 为什么会健胃消食呢
Lucia: Why does it aid digestion?
Alice:健胃消食片是饭前吃的
Alice: Digestive tablets are taken before meals.
Shure: 啥时候吃都行
Shure: You can take them anytime.
Shure: 你想起来吃就行
Shure: Just take them whenever you remember.
Tasha: 那你要饭前吃
Tasha: But you should take them before meals.
Tasha: 不
Tasha: No.
Tasha: 就是做好这顿要大吃一顿的准备了
Tasha: That means you're ready to eat a big meal.
Tasha: 是吗
Tasha: Right?
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake:那要吃少了是不是就会饿
Jake: If you eat less, will you still be hungry?
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈那要没吃够预期的话
Lucia: Hahaha, what if you didn't meet your expectation?
Jake:对
Jake: Exactly.
Lucia: 不就白吃了吗
Lucia: Wouldn't it be a waste?
Jake:就没吃就比方说中午没有吃到
Jake: So if you didn't eat, like if you didn't eat lunch...
Jake:然后中午就会就会饿晚上就会多吃
Jake: Then you'll be hungry at noon and eat more at night.
Shure: 喂
Shure: Hey
Lucia: 大晚上你不知道自己会吃那么多
Lucia: You don't know you'll eat so much late at night.
Shure: 啊
Shure: Ah
Jake:对是的
Jake: Yes, that's right.
Katrina: 好可怜的水
Katrina: Poor water.
Shure: 我没有我们宿舍
Shure: I don't have it in our dorm.
Jake:哈哈哈是这么回事
Jake: Hahaha, that's how it is.
Shure: 那个碎的
Shure: The broken one.
Tasha: 这有这有
Tasha: There's some here.
Shure: 嗯你问问那个王少他们宿舍
Shure: Hmm, ask Wang Shao's dorm.
Lucia: 别说我CUP都要烧了
Lucia: Don't say it, my CUP is about to burn.
Shure: 小泽他妈也碎了
Shure: Xiao Ze's mom's also broke.
Shure: 卧槽怎么都碎了
Shure: Damn, why is everything breaking?
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 谁谁又发烧了
Tasha: Who has a fever again?
Shure: 他怎么打电话不说拜拜就挂电话呀
Shure: Why does he hang up without saying bye?
Shure: 他好没礼貌啊真的
Shure: He's so rude, seriously.
Jake:啥呀
Jake: What?
Tasha: 他好像也发烧了不知道
Tasha: He seems to have a fever too, not sure.
Jake:不
Jake: No
Tasha: 呀
Tasha: Ah
Shure: 谢边竹嘛
Shure: Xie Bianzhu?
Jake:就谢民族吧
Jake: Just Xie Minzu.
Alice:他昨天晚上回去了
Alice: He went back last night.
Shure: 啊但他昨天晚上回去了
Shure: Ah, but he went back last night.
其他人：他还烧着呢
Others: He's still burning.
Shure: 他烧着呢
Shure: He's still burning.
Shure: 他烧起来了现在
Shure: He's burning up now.
Lucia: 燃起来了嗯
Lucia: He's fired up, yeah.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Alice:燃起来了
Alice: He's fired up.
Jake:别来了刚先说说你烧起来吧
Jake: Don't come, just talk about your fever.
Lucia: 刚修硕说你烧起来吧
Lucia: Shure just said you're fired up.
Shure: 你不应该想到骚起来
Shure: You shouldn't think about being flirty.
Shure: 哈哈哈你怎么这么正经
Shure: Hahaha, why are you so serious?
Lucia: 下次一定
Lucia: Next time for sure.
Lucia: 你现在给我建议了一个语库联系
Lucia: Now you gave me a vocabulary suggestion.
Shure: 啊对
Shure: Ah, right.
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 就是这个
Shure: It's this
Shure: 被打断了之后那个线上就死立不掉了
Shure: Once it's interrupted, the online thing just can't go away
Shure: 你知道吧
Shure: You know?
Jake:哈
Jake: Huh
Shure: 大兴
Shure: Daxing
Lucia: 那个莲花白还挺好吃的
Lucia: That lotus white cabbage is pretty tasty
Alice:哪个这个
Alice: Which one?
Alice:给你个呢
Alice: Here you go
Lucia: 啊谢谢谢谢
Lucia: Ah, thanks, thanks
Alice:你们你们那叫啥
Lucia: 莲花白
Lucia: Lotus white cabbage
Shure: 哦还行
Shure: Oh, it's alright
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you guys call it?
Alice:圆白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage
Shure: 你坐19号线很快
Shure: If you take Line 19, it's quick
Shure: 一个小时就能到
Shure: You'll get there in an hour
Alice:洋白菜圆白菜
Alice: Round cabbage, round cabbage
Shure: 嗯 6点出门是完全来得及的
Shure: Yeah, leaving at 6, you'll make it in time
Katrina: 白菜
Katrina: Cabbage
Alice:白菜
Alice: Cabbage
其他人：6点出门天还没亮
Others: Leaving at 6, it's not even light out
Katrina: 包菜包菜
Katrina: Wrapped cabbage, wrapped cabbage
Jake:包菜包菜
Jake: Wrapped cabbage, wrapped cabbage
Jake:包菜包菜是
Jake: Wrapped cabbage is
Shure: 亮了6点半
Shure: It gets light at 6:30
Lucia:  对圆白菜也
Lucia: Yeah, round cabbage too
Lucia: 我们那边也这么叫
Lucia: We call it that too
Lucia: 但是一般可能做两个吧
Lucia: But usually, we might make two kinds
Shure: 6点半必须出门
Shure: You have to leave at 6:30
Shure: 才一小时7分钟
Shure: It's only an hour and 7 minutes
Shure: 还得去个安检什么的
Shure: You still have to go through security and all
Alice:包包菜可爱
Alice: Wrapped cabbage is cute
Alice:莲花白
Alice: Lotus white cabbage
Shure: 只能怪
Shure: Can only blame
Katrina: 我靠这音乐姐真的想去
Katrina: Wow, this music really makes me wanna go
其他人：11点之后
Others: After 11
其他人：我还得从T2跑到T1去找我朋友去
Others: I still have to run from T2 to T1 to find my friend
Alice:没关系
Alice: It's okay
Shure: 他先到北京
Shure: He arrives in Beijing first
Shure: 哦
Shure: Oh
Alice:莲花白这个名字明显比圆白菜好吃
Alice: "Lotus white" sounds much tastier than "cabbage."
Shure: 我记得你飞到浦东还是虹桥
Shure: I remember you flew to Pudong or Hongqiao.
Jake:就这个东西叫
Jake: This thing is called
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm
Jake:嗯
Jake: Hmm
Shure: 虹桥虹桥
Shure: Hongqiao, Hongqiao.
Lucia: 你们叫啥
Lucia: What do you guys call it?
Jake:就包菜
Jake: Just cabbage.
Jake:很粗暴
Jake: Very crude.
Lucia: 我还以为这个名字是叠词包包菜
Lucia: I thought the name was "double cabbage."
Jake:包包菜
Jake: Double cabbage.
Shure: 不止几百米吧
Shure: Not just a few hundred meters, right?
Alice:洋芋是土豆吗
Alice: Is "yangyu" the same as "potato"?
Alice:我们那不这么叫洋芋
Alice: We don't call it "yangyu" where I'm from.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yes.
Alice:地瓜红薯
Alice: Sweet potato.
Lucia: 地瓜
Lucia: Sweet potato.
Alice:洋芋
Alice: Potato.
Lucia: 在我们那红薯就叫地瓜然后土豆叫洋芋
Lucia: Where I'm from, sweet potatoes are called "di gua" and potatoes are called "yangyu."
Lucia: 都叫
Lucia: They're all called...
Lucia: 再往西北走的话就要多一点
Lucia: If you go further northwest, you'll see more of it.
Lucia: 比如说甘肃
Lucia: For example, Gansu.
Alice:不叫洋芋
Alice: They don't call it "yangyu."
Jake:就就不叫土豆了
Jake: They don't call it "potato."
Lucia: 大家也知道土豆是什么
Lucia: But everyone knows what a potato is.
Lucia: 哦不不怎么叫哦
Lucia: Oh, but they don't really call it that.
Alice:我们那不用洋芋这个名
Alice: We don't use the name "yangyu."
Alice:所以你说洋芋可能就有的
Alice: So if you say "yangyu," some people...
Alice:不就不知道啥
Alice: might not know what it is.
Alice:我们就是土豆
Alice: We just say "potato."
Lucia: 那你们洋葱叫什么
Lucia: What do you call onions then?
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onions.
Alice:阿年哈哈哈哈
Alice: Ah yeah, haha.
Lucia: 就是啊啊呀
Lucia: Exactly, ah yeah.
Lucia: 比如说甘肃和陕西是吧
Lucia: For example, in Gansu and Shaanxi, right?
Tasha: 我问你是吧
Tasha: Are you asking me?
Alice:不知道
Alice: I don't know.
Lucia: 甘肃和新疆那边叫皮牙子
Lucia: In Gansu and Xinjiang, they call it "pi ya zi."
Alice:什么
Alice: What?
Lucia: 皮牙子
Lucia: Onion
Jake:皮牙子
Jake: Onion
Lucia: 我也不知道为什么这么叫
Lucia: I don't know why it's called that
Lucia: 听着有点喜感
Lucia: It sounds kind of funny
Lucia: 但是总之就是那边会这么叫
Lucia: But that's what they call it over there
Alice:还有什么啊
Alice: What else?
Tasha: 我想起来皮燕子
Tasha: I remembered "pi yan zi"
Jake:哈哈哈体验的是什么啊
Jake: Hahaha, what does it feel like?
Alice:啊哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahahahahahahaha
Lucia: 这个要给他解释吗
Lucia: Should we explain this to him?
Tasha: 哈哈哈不要了
Tasha: Hahaha, no need
Jake:好对不起
Jake: Okay, sorry
Lucia: 你多上中文互联网冲一下
Lucia: You should browse the Chinese internet more
Tasha: 不好不好意思我不是在故意的
Tasha: Sorry, I didn't mean to
Tasha: 吃饭的时候
Tasha: While eating
Tasha: 吃饭的时候说这个
Tasha: Talking about this while eating
Alice:哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha
Tasha: 什么
Tasha: What?
Jake:可能是吧
Jake: Maybe
Jake:回头冲冲浪
Jake: Surf the web later
Alice:杨老板昨天的照片太显年轻
Alice: Jake, yesterday's photo made you look so young
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: GPT里
Tasha: In GPT
Jake:嗯就是
Jake: Yeah, exactly
Alice:了
Alice: Yep
Jake:头像头像
Jake: The profile picture
Shure: 绝学南航APP
Shure: The ultimate skill, Nanhang APP
Alice:你喜欢这番茄酱
Alice: Do you like this ketchup?
其他人：小众爱好
Others: Niche hobby
Tasha: 这这爱好不小众
Tasha: This hobby isn't niche
Tasha: 我也喜欢
Tasha: I like it too
Shure: 24号就是后天了
Shure: The 24th is the day after tomorrow
Alice:咋了
Alice: What's up?
Alice:来得及
Alice: There's still time
Shure: 放弃了
Shure: Gave up
Alice:放弃了
Alice: Gave up
Shure: 但是有购买记录了
Shure: But there's a purchase record
Shure: 就是他他死无对证这个事情
Shure: So he can't deny it
Shure: 因为他到期那个资源就给给我释放了
Shure: Because when it expired, the resource was released to me
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh
Shure: 对所以我说我训过
Shure: Yeah, so I said I have trained before.
Shure: 他又不知道我训没训过是吧
Shure: He doesn't know whether I have trained or not, right?
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Alice:吃完了
Alice: Finished eating.
Alice:牛逼不嫌酸
Alice: Not bad, not too sour.
Lucia: 而且我今天是周二嘛
Lucia: And today is Tuesday, right?
其他人：刚想回去喝点水哈哈
Others: Just wanted to go back and drink some water, haha.
Alice:洋葱
Alice: Onion.
Shure: 是啊
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 我之前会去他们APP
Shure: I used to go to their app.
Shure: 上看就比如我去
Shure: And look for example, I go...
Shure: 他没说什么时候
Shure: He didn't say when.
Alice:下午几点录房间呢
Alice: What time are we recording the room in the afternoon?
Alice:现在收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's tidy up now.
Jake:现在吧
Jake: Now, right?
Jake:就是
Jake: Exactly.
Jake:尽快吧
Jake: As soon as possible.
Alice:尽快
Alice: As soon as possible.
Jake:吃完吃完收拾收拾
Jake: Finish eating, then tidy up.
Jake:我开始扫
Jake: I'll start sweeping.
Jake:你们在外面待着
Jake: You guys stay outside.
Alice:那我去收拾一下下
Alice: Then I'll go tidy up a bit.
Jake:或者在4月30
Jake: Or maybe on April 30th...
Lucia: 还要再扫一遍
Lucia: Need to sweep again.
Jake:不要扫
Jake: No need to sweep.
Jake:扫一遍你们装饰之后的就长不一样了
Jake: Sweeping after you decorate will look different.
Jake:呵呵呵是吧
Jake: Haha, right?
Alice:找不同
Alice: Spot the difference.
Lucia: 有一些有一些
Lucia: Some, some.
Lucia: 美容值掉下来了
Lucia: The beauty value dropped.
Lucia: 我再回去粘一下
Lucia: I'll go back and stick it again.
Alice:对
Alice: Right.
Jake:好嘞那我先扫你的
Jake: Okay, I'll sweep yours first.
Jake:先扫你的屋子哦
Jake: Sweep your room first, okay.
Lucia: 你说我粘好之后哦
Lucia: You mean after I stick it?
Tasha: 现在就是扫装饰完的是吗
Tasha: Now we sweep after decorating, right?
Jake:嗯嗯嗯
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Alice:我的也快扫吧因为我那个胶
Alice: You can sweep mine soon too because my glue...
Shure: 我很少做南航的
Shure: I rarely take Southern Airlines.
Jake:好好
Jake: Okay, sure.
Lucia: 哦对
Lucia: Oh right.
Alice:他老掉对对对
Alice: It always falls off, yeah yeah.
Shure: 我
Shure: I...
Lucia:  我今天早上起来发现他又掉了
Lucia: I found out this morning it fell off again.
Lucia: 那我以为不用了
Lucia: So I thought we didn't need it.
Lucia: 我就没粘
Lucia: I didn't stick it back.
Lucia: 我想在上面粘一下然后再粘
Lucia: I was thinking to stick it back again later.
Alice:我全都在粘
Alice: I've been sticking everything.
Jake:那我先扫二楼
Jake: Then I'll clean the second floor first.
Jake:我先扫你的屋子
Jake: I'll clean your room first.
Jake:然后你的屋子
Jake: Then your room.
Jake:二楼就
Jake: The second floor...
Jake:我在二楼的时候你们就在一楼待着
Jake: When I'm on the second floor, you guys stay on the first floor.
Jake:然后你可以在一楼再贴一贴
Jake: Then you can stick things on the first floor again.
Jake:我下来的时候你就上去
Jake: When I come down, you go up.
Alice:可以可以
Alice: Sure, sure.
Jake:就这么回事
Jake: That's the plan.
Alice:在院子应该也行都一样
Alice: It should be fine in the yard too, it's all the same.
Alice:怎么了
Alice: What's up?
Alice:我去别掉了烦死了
Alice: Ugh, I hope it doesn't fall off again, it's so annoying.
其他人：算了什么时候拍什么时候粘吧
Others: Whatever, let's just stick it when we shoot.
Alice:真嘟吗他不会稀里哗啦全掉了吧
Alice: Is it reliable though? It won't just all fall off, right?
Alice:不是没有这个可能
Alice: It's not impossible.
其他人：哎呀没关系啊
Others: Ah, it's fine.
Alice:先收拾一下吧
Alice: Let's tidy up first.
其他人：再迟早的事
Others: It'll happen sooner or later.
Alice:迟早的事
Alice: Sooner or later.
其他人：哦这鲜花
Others: Oh, these flowers.
Alice:不然呢
Alice: What else?
Alice:我请问
Alice: May I ask?
其他人：长的太像塑料的了
Others: They look too much like plastic.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Haha.
Alice:我多想是路过你的风
Alice: I wish I was the wind passing by you.
Alice:啥玩意掉呢这这
Alice: What's falling now?
Alice:收拾衣服
Alice: Tidy up the clothes.
Alice:要不然直接就先把他扔进去好啦
Alice: Or we can just throw them in first.
Alice:下午再慢慢收吧
Alice: We can organize them slowly in the afternoon.
Alice:你觉得怎样
Alice: What do you think?
Alice:这个也扔进去吧
Alice: Throw this in too.
Alice:这是你包里吧
Alice: Is this from your bag?
其他人：什么呢玩意
Others: What's this thing?
Alice:这你东西吗
Alice: Is this yours?
其他人：那籽是吧行
Others: Is that a seed?
Alice:还有啥没扔进去的
Alice: Is there anything else we haven't thrown in?
Alice:差不多了
Alice: Almost done.
Alice:不过我那个床可以先不收拾
Alice: But my bed can be left alone for now.
Alice:呆会我不是还躺吗
其他人：小姐姐你
Others: Miss, you...
Alice:小姐姐我好的很呢
Alice: Miss, I'm doing just fine.
Alice:小姐姐
Alice: Miss...
Alice:躺了一会
Alice: Lying down for a bit.
Alice:你这感觉是收拾家伙
Alice: You seem to be packing up your stuff.
Alice:是要跑路呢
Alice: Are you planning to run away?
其他人：这是什么玩意
Others: What is this thing?
Alice:哎呀这是一个丑丑的东西
Alice: Oh, it's an ugly thing.
Alice:你就扔那吧
Alice: Just throw it over there.
Alice:别管他了丑啊
Alice: Don't mind it, it's ugly.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:你把那个粘上吧给
Alice: Stick that thing on, please.
Alice:你摸摸呢
Alice: Feel it.
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
Alice:你有了你就受死吧刘婷
Alice:这不是
Alice: This isn't...
其他人：你藏那干嘛
Others: Why are you hiding it there?
Alice:我请问我藏胶带干嘛
Alice: Why would I hide the tape?
其他人：你的纸你都贴一个角
Others: Your paper, you stuck it on one corner.
Alice:你干嘛你放屁
Alice: What are you talking about? You're lying.
Alice:那是因为我原来贴上的
Alice: That's because I originally stuck it there.
其他人：放屁呢
Others: You're lying, you pulled it to that side.
Alice:你往那边拉了太扯了太太太那啥了
Alice:所以就显不得他了
Alice: So it can't be shown.
Alice:你放哈哈哈哈
Alice: You put... hahaha...
Alice:笑死我啦
Alice: You're killing me with laughter.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:呵呵呵
Alice: Hehehe...
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:我靠这墙皮不准掉
Alice: Damn, the wall skin better not fall off.
Alice:妈的再给我撑一会
Alice: Damn, hold on a bit longer.
Alice:哈哈我要碎了
Alice: Haha, I'm about to break
Alice:哈哈
Alice: Haha
其他人：实在不行看看厨房里有没有这个黄的
Others: If it really doesn't work, check the kitchen for the yellow one
其他人：咱们破一下
Others: Let's break it
Alice:我靠你别在那瞎搞
Alice: Oh my, don't mess around
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Hey girl, you
Alice:哎我手机呢
Alice: Hey, where's my phone
Alice:我怎么没把手机拿回来没
Alice: How come I didn't get my phone back
Alice:真服了手机不知道扔哪去了
Alice: Seriously, I have no idea where I threw my phone
Alice:手机是不是给外面装上了
Alice: Did I leave my phone outside
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Hey girl, you
Alice:我手机在这吗
Alice: Is my phone here
Lucia: 好像没有啊
Lucia: Seems like it's not here
Jake:没看着
Jake: Didn't see it
Alice:嗯那我扔哪了
Alice: Hmm, then where did I throw it
Alice:小姐姐你怎么乱扔手机呢
Alice: Girl, why do you throw your phone around
Alice:你怎么随地随地扔手机
Alice: Why do you throw your phone everywhere
Alice:随地大小鸡
Alice: Everywhere like a chicken
Alice:我干什么
Alice: What am I doing
其他人：我不知道啥时候成
Others: I don't know when it happened
Alice:你有毛病吧
Alice: Are you crazy
Alice:小偷
Alice: Thief
Alice:哈哈全都录着呢啊
Alice: Haha, it's all recorded
Alice:吃点瓜子
Alice: Let's eat some sunflower seeds
其他人：看这个颜色挺贴近的吧
Others: This color looks pretty close, right
其他人：这捣鼓捣鼓能不能
Others: Can we try to fix it
Alice:你拉倒吧
Alice: Give it a rest
Alice:你别搁那出点什么幺蛾子了
Alice: Stop messing around
Alice:当个正常人不好啊
Alice: What's wrong with being normal
其他人：咱走时是不是把这东西收拾一下
Others: Should we clean this up before we leave
Alice:对啊你可以现在就收拾
Alice: Yeah, you can clean it now
Alice:如果你闲的话
Alice: If you're free
其他人：收拾不下了
Others: Can't clean it up
Alice:喝个咖啡吧
Alice: Let's have a coffee
Alice:有点渴了
Alice: I'm a bit thirsty
Alice:你刷呗哎
Alice: You can brush it, hey
Alice:那个怎么就变形了呢
Alice: Why did it get deformed
Alice:没事你要刷你刷呗
Alice: It's okay, if you want to brush it, go ahead
Alice:这啊真的是变形的
Alice: This, it really is deformed
其他人：没看错啊
Others: Didn't see it wrong
其他人：呵呵哦
Others: Hehe, oh
Alice:这怎么回事
Alice: What's going on?
Alice:你要刷吗
Alice: Are you going to swipe?
Alice:我可以录着你
Alice: I can record you
其他人：做好事不留名
Alice:你可以说不录
Alice: You can say no to recording
Alice:但是你你的意思做好事不留名
Alice: But you mean doing good deeds anonymously
Alice:是你不做呀
Alice: Means you won't do it
Alice:啊是这意思呗
Alice: Ah, that's what you mean
Alice:果然小姐姐你啊
Alice: As expected, you're such a nice girl
Alice:你真刷
Alice: You're really swiping
其他人：不是
Others: No
其他人：他那个泡半天了
Others: He's been soaking for a while
其他人：因为我想把这地腾出来
Others: Because I want to clear this area
其他人：我想刷那个刷那个
Others: I want to swipe, swipe that
Alice:你为什么要刷他呢
Alice: Why do you want to swipe him?
Alice:那你那你刷吧
Alice: Well, then swipe
其他人：我网也不好
Others: My internet is bad too
其他人：我玩丢人格
Others: I keep losing connection
其他人：我也玩不太
Others: I can't really play either
Alice:那
Alice: Well
其他人：我就这点小众爱好
Others: I just have these niche hobbies
Alice:好
Alice: Okay
Alice:我准了
Alice: I approve
Alice:你都玩第五人格了
Alice: You're already playing Identity V
Alice:我有什么不准的呢
Alice: What can I disapprove of?
Alice:我这个豆
Alice: This bean
Alice:这是豆乳的那个
Alice: This is bean milk
Alice:洗洁精是不是快没了
Alice: Is the dish soap almost gone?
Alice:没了要不再买一盒
Alice: If it's gone, should we buy another box?
Alice:但是用的到吗
Alice: But will we use it?
其他人：看到钢丝球了
Others: Saw the steel wool
Alice:钢丝球搁那
Alice: The steel wool is there
Alice:你吃手指饼干吗
Alice: Do you want some finger biscuits?
Alice:刘婷你好贤惠
Alice: Liu Ting, you're so virtuous
Alice:我好喜欢
Alice: I really like it
Alice:哎呀我这个亮不亮
Alice: Oh, is this bright?
其他人：亮着呢亮着呢
Others: It's bright, it's bright
Alice:好呢
Alice: Good
Alice:还想再吃个瑞士卷咋办今天
Alice: I still want to eat a Swiss roll today, what should I do?
Alice:猪瘾上身了
Alice: Craving pork again.
Alice:就剩俩了
Alice: Only two left.
Alice:咱俩吃一个吧
Alice: Let's share one.
Alice:再给你掰个一半
Alice: I'll break half for you.
Alice:不吃
Alice: Not eating.
Alice:等会再吃
Alice: Eat it later.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:定下我们的任务就是打扫卫生
Alice: Our task is to clean.
Alice:干嘛的
Alice: What are we doing?
Alice:打扫卫生
Alice: Cleaning.
Alice:真的吗你很喜欢打扫卫生吗
Alice: Really? Do you like cleaning?
其他人： 就因为看着太乱了
Others: Just because it's too messy.
其他人：有点糟心
Others: It's a bit annoying.
Alice:哈哈好
Alice: Haha, okay.
Lucia: 你星星别忘带走了
Lucia: Don't forget your star.
Alice:什么星星什么星星哦
Alice: What star? Oh, that star.
Alice:谁要把我这个偷了
Alice: Who wants to steal this from me?
Alice:我得把他祖坟给刨了哈哈
Alice: I'll dig up their ancestors' graves, haha.
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:准备
Alice: Ready.
Alice:我们田真是田螺姑娘呢
Alice: Our Tian is really like the snail girl.
Alice:you我直接爱上
Alice: You, I just fell in love instantly.
Alice:这个应该不喝了
Alice: This one shouldn't be drunk anymore.
Alice:都给他扔了吧
Alice: Just throw it away.
Alice:这是垃圾桶吗
Alice: Is this a trash can?
Alice:变成five
Alice: Turned into five.
其他人：应该是
Others: Probably.
Alice:波比波比波波比波
Alice: Bobby bobby bob bob bobby bob.
其他人：波比波比波波比波
Others: Bobby bobby bob bob bobby bob.
Alice:做好事不留名
Alice: Doing good deeds without leaving a name.
Alice:怎么啦
Alice: What's up?
其他人：这屋真乱
Others: This place is really messy.
Alice:哈哈可以
Alice: Haha, okay.
Alice:嗯嗯啊
Alice: Uh-huh.
Alice:啊呀我的充电宝可别掉
Alice: Ah, don't drop my power bank.
其他人：我操我以为你腰闪了
Others: Damn, I thought you threw your back out.
Alice:我有那么大年纪吗
Alice: Am I that old?
Alice:我干一点活我就腰闪了啊
Alice: Do a little work and I throw my back out?
其他人：说不准
Others: You never know.
Alice:你把姐当成什么了
Alice: What do you take me for?
Alice:真他妈的无语了
Alice: Damn, I'm speechless.
Alice:这葱不要了
Alice: Forget about these green onions.
Alice:萨瓦迪卡欢迎大家
Alice: Sawasdee ka, welcome everyone.
Alice:这个蛋还能要不了
Alice: Can we still use this egg or not?
Alice:要吗
Alice: Do you want it?
Alice:我靠这水煮蛋能吃吗
Alice: Gosh, can this boiled egg be eaten?
其他人：还算了
Others: Just forget it.
Alice:算了扔了
Alice: Forget it, throw it away.
Alice:扔了
Alice: Throw it away.
其他人：中午也不是没吃饱
Others: We didn't really eat much at lunch anyway.
Alice:也是啊
Alice: That's true.
Alice:扔掉了
Alice: Throw it away.
Alice:波比波比波波比波
Alice: Bobby bobby bo bobby bo.
Alice:（歌词）想你的夜
Alice: (lyrics) Missing you at night.
Alice:知道你心里
Alice: Knowing in your heart.
Alice:咋了你以为啥
Alice: What's up? What did you think?
Alice:还能否为我改变
Alice: Will you still change for me?
Alice:想你的夜
Alice: Missing you at night.
Alice:对啊随便吧
Alice: Yeah, like a sailor.
Alice:哎在在这
Alice: Hey, here, here.
其他人：刷一刷别动
Others: Wipe it, don't move.
Alice:不用刷了
Alice: No need to wipe it.
Alice:直接刚刚刷过的
Alice: It was just wiped.
Alice:偶买噶的偶买噶这些直接扔掉就好了
Alice: Oh my god, just throw these away.
其他人：这不要了
Others: We don't need this.
Alice:对还有这
Alice: Yeah, and this too.
其他人：这不是他那
Others: Isn't this his?
Alice:不用了啊
Alice: We don't need it.
其他人：这不是他那自带的吗
Others: Isn't this what he brought?
Jake:就是因为这个
Jake: It's because of this.
Alice:不是啊这我们全是我们买的
Alice: No, we bought all of this.
Alice:这本来啥都没有
Alice: There was nothing here originally.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:好啥呀
Alice: What's good?
Alice:靠这个碗都粘不到一块了
Alice:哇哦
Alice: Wow.
Alice:不封口不封口
Alice: Don't close it, don't close it.
Alice:等着受潮呢
Alice: It's going to get damp.
Alice:小姐姐你如此贤惠
Alice: Miss, you are so virtuous.
Alice:不要命啦
Alice: Are you out of your mind?
Alice:小姐姐你
Alice: Miss, you...
Alice:真嘟假嘟
其他人：薄荷叶也不要了
Others: We don't need the mint leaves anymore.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：蔫了
Others: They wilted.
Alice:薄荷叶肯定不要了
Alice: We definitely don't need the mint leaves anymore.
Alice:你可以回家泡澡
Alice: You can go home and take a bath.
其他人：是你们拿的
Others: It was you guys who took them.
Alice:是的
Alice: Yes.
其他人：牙刷是
Others: The toothbrush is...
Alice:不道谁的
Alice: I don't know whose.
Alice:有点不雅
Alice: It's a bit improper.
Alice:哼哼还好没人看到
Alice: Luckily no one saw it.
Alice:没关呀我的意思我拿脚踩这个垃圾
Alice: No worries, I meant I stepped on this trash with my foot.
其他人：这镯子是谁的
Others: Whose bracelet is this?
Alice:镯子搁那吧打游戏裂开了
Alice: Just leave the bracelet there, it broke during the game.
其他人：不是你的吧
Others: It's not yours, right?
Alice:不是我了
Alice: It's not mine.
Alice:你见我戴过这个吗
Alice: Have you ever seen me wear this?
Alice:你竟然对我一点都不上心呢
Alice: You're not paying any attention to me at all.
Alice:你怎么回事
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Alice:我没玉镯啊
Alice: I don't have a jade bracelet.
Alice:哦有倒是有
Alice: Oh wait, I do.
Alice:你不觉得我那个比他粗好多吗
Alice: Don't you think mine is much thicker?
Alice:不上心呢你刘婷
Alice: You're not paying attention to me, Liu Ting.
Alice:你怎么回事啊
Alice: What's wrong with you?
Alice:那你就是记错了
Alice: Then you must have remembered wrong.
Alice:伤了我的心
Alice: You've hurt my feelings.
Alice:你喝牛奶吗
Alice: Do you drink milk?
Alice:这能喝吗
Alice: Can you drink this?
其他人：还别了吧
Others: Better not.
Alice:这昨天晚上拿出来的
Alice: This was taken out last night.
Alice:拿咖啡液
Alice: Take the coffee liquid.
其他人：眼镜防雾湿巾也是你们的
Others: The anti-fog wipes for glasses are also yours.
Alice:全都是我们的
Alice: They're all ours.
Alice:跟你说这全是我们买的
Alice: I'm telling you, we bought all of this.
其他人：我拿点这个我需要
Others: I'll take some, I need it.
Alice:可以
Alice: Sure.
Alice:我当做你没看见吧就
Alice: I'll pretend I didn't see anything.
其他人：没看见
Others: Didn't see it.
Alice:嗯虽然这全是摄像头
Alice: Hmm, even though there are cameras everywhere.
Alice:无所谓你拿吧
Alice: It's fine, you can take it.
Alice:反正也没人用
Alice: Anyway, no one uses it.
Alice:可以让我喝个牛奶
Alice: Can I have some milk?
Alice:有你刚刷的杯子吗
Alice: Do you have the cup you just washed?
其他人：这都是
Others: These are all...
Alice:给我一个吧
Alice: Give me one.
Alice:我相信你啊
Alice: I trust you.
Alice:别给我被我毒死了婷
Alice: Just don't poison me, Ting.
其他人：什么毒死你
Others: What do you mean, poison you?
其他人：不是我这杯子是你牛奶兄弟
Others: No, the cup is yours, the milk is your brother's.
其他人：哈哈哈牛奶有毒
Alice:你你的香水有毒
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:一闻就没我的贵
Alice: Just a smell and it's not as expensive as mine.
Alice:咦嘿嘿小姐姐你
Alice: Eww, hey miss, you...
Alice:这蛋长得真好看刘婷
Alice: This egg looks really good, Liu Ting.
Alice:所以他好适合煮
Alice: So it's perfect for boiling.
Alice:this is a beautiful egg
Alice: This is a beautiful egg.
Alice:这蛋挞壳也不要了
Alice: Don't need this egg tart shell either.
Alice:伤过的心还可以爱谁
Alice: Who can love a broken heart?
其他人：这碗不会也是你们买的吧
Others: This bowl, you didn't buy it too, right?
Alice:好像是的都是的
Alice: Seems like it, all of it.
Alice:画完了刘婷你再给他刷一下吧
Alice: When you're done, Liu Ting, give it another wash.
Alice:谢谢小姐姐
Alice: Thanks, miss.
Alice:呵呵
Alice: Hehe.
其他人：喝完没变味吗那个
Others: Does it taste different after you drank it?
Alice:没有啊跟你说了昨天晚上拿出来的
Alice: No, I told you, I took it out last night.
Alice:哎我给你放个歌吧
Alice: Hey, let me play you a song.
Alice:刘婷看你这么辛苦
Alice: Liu Ting, you look so tired.
Alice:你想听什么呢
Alice: What do you want to hear?
Alice:我是会员哦
Alice: I have a membership.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 你刚才是叫我吗
Lucia: Were you calling me just now?
Alice:没有
Alice: No.
其他人：不是QQ音乐会员
Others: Not a QQ Music member.
Alice:给我封个口
Alice: Seal my lips.
Alice:捏不住我
Alice: You can't hold me.
其他人：你是肌无力吧
Others: Are you muscle weak or something?
其他人：你是
Others: You are
Alice:这不好捏
Alice: This is hard to handle.
Alice:我没看人家手里拿那么多东西呢
Alice: I haven't seen anyone holding so many things.
Alice:坏女坏坏坏女人
Alice: Bad woman, bad, bad, bad woman.
Alice:我靠真恶心
Alice: Damn, that's disgusting.
Alice:每次跟你在一块
Alice: Every time I'm with you,
Alice:我就像那个什么脏东西上身了一样
Alice: it's like I'm possessed by something dirty.
Alice:我知道
Alice: I know.
Alice:咋还非得过这个瘾
Alice: Why do you have to get this addicted?
Alice:对啊
Alice: Yeah.
Alice:我靠你你玩抽象的呀
Alice: Damn, you're playing abstract.
Alice:我我不知道谁那样洗啊
Alice: I don't know who washes like that.
Alice:不管就不管
Alice: Don't care then.
Alice:我还不乐意管嘞
Alice: I don't want to care anyway.
Alice:小姐姐你这这洗过的
Alice: Miss, did you wash this?
其他人：那边都洗过的
Others: It's all been washed over there.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:很支棱
Alice: Very spirited.
Alice:小姐姐你你太贤惠了
Alice: Miss, you are so good at this.
Alice:我直接爱上
Alice:喜欢刘天飞
Alice: I like Liu Tianfei.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Alice:哈这个需要查一查
Alice: Haha, this needs to be checked.
Alice:那是那是
Alice: That's right.
Alice:厨房卫生湿巾
Alice: Kitchen wipes.
Alice:上面有洗洁精之类的东西了啊
Alice: They have dish soap on them.
其他人：OK OK
Others: OK OK.
Alice:OK OK
Alice: OK OK.
Alice:筛子不要
Alice: No need for the sieve.
Alice:丢掉
Alice: Throw it away.
其他人：这黑板擦也你们的
Others: This blackboard eraser is yours too.
Alice:对搁这吧
Alice: Yeah, put it here.
其他人：无所谓用不着
Others: Doesn't matter, we don't need it.
Alice:可以
Alice: Alright.
Alice:我我给你放个歌吧
Alice: I'll play a song for you.
Alice:放什么呢
Alice: What should I play?
Alice:我婷姐你想听什么呢
Alice: Sister Ting, what do you want to listen to?
其他人：随便
Others: Anything.
Alice:好随便的女的好喜欢
Alice: Okay, I like easygoing girls.
Alice:首先啊
Alice: First of all...
其他人：来个林俊杰的吧
Others: Let's play a JJ Lin song.
Alice:林俊杰的啥
Alice: Which JJ Lin song?
其他人：来个林俊杰的吧
Others: Let's play a JJ Lin song.
Alice:好
Alice: Okay.
Alice:抄不用花钱
Alice: Copying doesn't cost money.
Alice:什么放啊
Alice: What? Just play it, go ahead and play it.
Alice:我哪敢说话呀
Alice: How dare I say anything?
Alice:不潮
Alice: Not trendy.
Alice:不花钱
Alice: Doesn't cost money.
Alice:看这是不是会员才能听呢嗯是呢
Alice: Look, is this only available to members? Yeah, it is.
Alice:就放这让你听
Alice: Just play it here for you to listen.
其他人：ok
Others: Okay.
其他人：你别忘了你手机
Others: Don't forget your phone.
Alice:这是不是没有啊
Alice: Is it not there?
Alice:没有了
Alice: It's gone.
其他人：有底
Others: There's a bit left.
Alice:是不是还要再买一瓶
Alice: Should we buy another bottle?
Alice:需要吗
Alice: Do we need it?
其他人：我觉这屋大概是用不
Others: I think this room probably doesn't...
其他人：上了
Others: Need it.
Alice:那就这样吧好
Alice: Then let's leave it at that, okay?
其他人：是吧
Others: Right?
Alice:音量您觉得如何呢
Alice: How do you feel about the volume?
Alice:哇小姐姐你唱歌太好听了吧
Alice: Wow, young lady, your singing is so good!
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：这还有几个草莓
Others: There are still a few strawberries left.
Alice:等会吧我不想吃现在
Alice: Wait a bit, I don't want to eat now.
Alice:卡壳了呢
Alice: It's stuck.
Alice:难怪你不打游戏了
Alice: No wonder you don't play games anymore.
Alice:是我我也不打了
Alice: If it were me, I wouldn't play either.
Shure: 真是人啊你
Shure: You're really something.
Jake:哎你这纹的啥呀
Jake: Hey, what did you get tattooed there?
Shure: 我刚刚换裤子换一半没换完
Shure: I was just changing my pants halfway, didn't finish.
Shure: 他出来然后就叭把门敞
Shure: Then he came out and just left the door wide open.
Jake:没有没有
Jake: No, no.
Jake:你说哪边
Jake: Which side are you talking about?
Shure: 我说这边
Shure: I'm talking about this side.
Jake:有有有这么个方向
Jake: Yeah, there's something in that direction.
其他人：没关系看不到我
Others: It's okay, we can't see it.
Jake:这是你的重生之日吗
Jake: Is today your rebirth day?
Shure: 真不见外
Shure: You're really not shy.
Shure: 怎么喜欢share一下
Shure: Why do you like to share so much?
Shure: 是吗哈
Shure: Really, huh.
Shure: 我怎么穿上跟流氓一样
Shure: Why do I look like a thug in this?
其他人：我就说这件衣服跟你像
Others: I told you, this outfit suits you.
其他人：有点特别像
Others: It really does.
Jake:挺好看的嗯
Jake: It looks pretty good, yeah.
Jake:有什么面啊
Jake: What kind of noodles do you have?
Jake:gold
Jake: Gold.
Alice:这谁眼镜啊
Alice: Whose glasses are these?
Alice:这谁的眼镜吗
Shure: 啊我的我的我的谢谢
Shure: Ah, mine, mine, mine, thanks.
Shure: 这小哨我拿着
Shure: I'll hold onto this whistle.
Shure: 文胸武肚生道里
Shure: Bras and martial stomachs in the path.
Shure: 那我应该我是文还是武文吧
Shure: So should I be the literary or martial one? Literary, I guess.
Alice:有必要刷吗这
Alice: Is it necessary to brush this?
其他人：我看这里面真有洗洁精
Others: I see there's really dish soap in here.
其他人：我的天呐
Others: Oh my god.
Alice:我骗你干啥呀姐妹
Alice: Why would I lie to you, sister?
Alice:姐妹啥时候骗过你呢
Alice: When have I ever lied to you?
Alice:我就请问呢
Alice: I'm just asking.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
Alice:啥时候骗过你
Alice: When have I ever lied to you?
Alice:喔什么声音
Alice: Oh, what's that sound?
Alice:啊手上好黏
Alice: Ah, my hands are so sticky.
Alice:我想嗑瓜子了
Alice: I want to eat some sunflower seeds.
其他人：磕呗
Others: Go ahead.
Alice:先嗑一个
Alice: Let me have one first.
Alice:嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Alice:聪明
Alice: Smart.
Alice:苏梅我不想吃草莓
Alice: Sumei, I don't want to eat strawberries.
Alice:你想吃吗
Alice: Do you want some?
Alice:想吃我给你洗一下
Alice: If you want, I'll wash some for you.
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah.
其他人：我自己洗
Others: I'll wash them myself.
Alice:咋我洗不干净啊
Alice: What, you think I can't wash them clean enough?
其他人：对哈哈
Others: Yes, haha.
Alice:我靠真是的
Alice: Gosh, really.
Alice:对你好你还
Alice: Alright, fine, you...
Alice:你还挑毛病
Alice: You're still picking faults
Alice:你这人是不是欠骂
Alice: Do you want to get scolded?
其他人：这还有草莓你吃吗
Others: There are still strawberries, do you want to eat?
Alice:草莓吃
Alice: I'll eat strawberries
Lucia: 吃
Lucia: Eat
其他人：还有两个
Others: There are two left
Alice:没洗吧
Alice: They’re not washed, right?
其他人：对没洗
Others: Right, not washed
Alice:你不给洗一下
Alice: Can't you wash them?
Lucia: 没事我来洗
Lucia: It's okay, I'll wash them
Alice:扔扔
Alice: Throw them away
Alice:我不吃
Alice: I'm not eating
其他人：谁跟你似的
Others: Who's like you?
其他人：那么懒哎呦我
Others: So lazy, oh my
Alice:我我我哪懒了
Alice: How am I lazy?
其他人：别让我在地上画点瓜子皮
Others: Don't make me draw lines with sunflower seeds on the floor
其他人：你小心点
Others: Be careful
Alice:哎你的掉了
Alice: Hey, you dropped something
Alice:可能手有点大
Alice: Maybe your hands are a bit too big
Lucia: 谢谢哎
Lucia: Thank you, hey
Lucia: 怎么回事
Lucia: What's going on?
Lucia: 可能是我刚才换衣服的时候
Lucia: Maybe it happened when I changed clothes just now
Lucia: 啊我应该是换衣服时把它揣口袋了
Lucia: Ah, I must've put it in my pocket when I changed clothes
Alice:没干系
Alice: No worries
Alice:我把电给你拔了啊
Alice: I'll unplug the power for you
Lucia: 因为我又要洗裤子了
Lucia: Because I need to wash my pants again
Alice:拔吧
Alice: Go ahead and unplug it
Alice:省了再给你
Alice: Save it and give it back to you later
Alice:没有天呐
Alice: Oh my god, no way
Alice:可不嘛
Alice: Exactly
其他人：吃顿饭真不容易啊
Others: It's not easy to have a meal
Alice:给
Alice: Here you go
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah
Lucia: 最后俩你要不要吃一个
Lucia: Do you want to eat one of the last two?
Lucia: 我我慷慨都分给你一个
Lucia: I'll generously share one with you
Alice:啊拆不下来了
Alice: Ah, I can't get it off
其他人：我来
Others: Let me help
Alice:你我靠
Alice: Oh my god
Alice:这奶油熏死我了
Alice: This cream is suffocating me
Alice:我不爱闻这个味
Alice: I don't like this smell
其他人：这是拧吗
Others: Is this twisting?
Alice:嗯扭一下
Alice: Yeah, twist it a bit.
Lucia: 柯欣和他的小伙伴
Lucia: Ke Xin and his little friends.
Alice:好你是你是真牛逼
Alice: Wow, you're really amazing.
Lucia: 慷慨的分给了我两个
Lucia: Generously gave me two.
Lucia: 你要不要慷慨的
Lucia: Do you want to be generous too?
Jake:那我慷我怎么慷慨
Jake: How can I be generous?
Lucia: 哈哈哈你要不
Lucia: Hahaha, do you want to?
Jake:哈哈哈我还能如何
Jake: Hahaha, what else can I do?
Lucia: 慷慨的还是留给我
Lucia: Leave the generosity to me.
Lucia: 哈哈哈没事没事你吃一个嘛
Lucia: Hahaha, it's okay, it's okay, you eat one.
Jake:好的慷慨了
Jake: Alright, I'll be generous.
Jake:那我吃一个
Jake: Then I'll eat one.
Lucia: 你看我相当于分给你1/2的水果
Lucia: Look, I gave you half of my fruit.
Lucia: 我是不是特别慷慨
Lucia: Am I not super generous?
Jake:嗯对谢谢各位慷慨
Jake: Yeah, thanks everyone for being generous.
Alice:老板
Alice: Boss.
Alice:我的生命危一危险
Alice: My life is in danger.
Alice:对我的生命安全受到了威胁
Alice: My personal safety is threatened.
其他人：哦生命危险受到了威胁
Others: Oh, your life is threatened.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahaha.
Alice:哈哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Alice:他要在地上翻一个瓜子皮就把我腰斩
Alice: He will cut me in half if there's a sunflower seed shell on the floor.
Alice:已经有了哈哈哈
Alice: It's already happened, hahaha.
Lucia: life danger is secured
Lucia: Life danger is secured.
Jake:哎
Jake: Hey.
Jake:你要采集一些不能播的数据
Jake: You need to collect some data that can't be broadcast.
Lucia: 笑的我都噎住了
Lucia: I'm laughing so hard I'm choking.
Alice:啊采集些不能拨的数据
Alice: Ah, collecting data that can't be broadcast.
Jake:就是采没有没有
Jake: Just collect, no no.